what does a woman expect from a man this
ties in don't worry don't worry you know
i like the transitions people you have i
like how you do like a shoulder bop
whenever you make a good point that
shoulders are bopping shoulders above it
okay let's go we're going to play this
one and we're going to talk about it
this is this is
amazing
okay for me he has to give me the life
that i want
he has to give you life that you want
okay what is that life exactly
spoil me live in a mansion buy me a
bugatti take wherever i want buy me
whatever i want fantastic and what do
you bring back to that man
and what do you give back to that man me
yes
this all of this
so you were able to delineate exactly
which one but you cannot delineate what
you bring yeah i bring myself to the
table okay okay so let's take a look the
reason that this came up for me is
because you were talking about boys
night out and like these caricatures
that we have women and of men
first of all those are your friends by
the way yeah those are your friends
right you're fresh and fit yeah okay
they're ridiculous really they're
ridiculous who's more ridiculous
okay well
they are on a mission i think it's
pretty obvious to everybody they're on a
mission to make women look bad and to
wake make women look like that you want
to have fresh effect you want to have a
real ass woman come on and tell you what
she wants from man have me on they're
having all of these girls set this up
girls these are not women okay these are
girls and what she's talking about is
glorified prostitution
yeah that's what she's talking about so
he has them on they have them on their
team i know i don't know much about them
but i know they were on your podcast
they did a good job i've been on their
podcast
podcast i disagree with them 99 of the
time respect what they're doing they're
doing a show they're making their money
yeah but
this is a character of a female
women they're not putting words in her
mouth yeah he said what do you do
and what do you think they hunt out when
they want to put a girl on the show
someone who's going to say that you
think they're going to want me to come
on and say when they say oh what do you
want from man me to say oh i want a
really good sense of humor i want
somebody who's gonna you know be able to
talk to me and communicate they're not
looking for that answer they're looking
for that answer they can say oh women
are all about this and guys you need to
you know know your value and you come on
so give me how do you feel about what
you said right there how do i feel about
them or what she's how do you feel about
what she said right there she says she's
basically saying i'm the prize yeah
i'm the prize and you got to take care
of me you got to take care of well i
can't talk to them
you got to understand what they're doing
like you're saying that they're there to
diminish women or they're to paint a
character of women so that they can make
their point their talking point about
men i think what they're doing is
they're they're there to
wake men up
now you might be like what do you mean
so because i've sat down on that table
they've been on our chair
they don't wake up every day and say i'm
telling you they don't like we gotta
[ __ ] these hoes bro we gotta [ __ ] them
up we gotta show we gotta we gotta
expose them we gotta we gotta make them
look stupid no they actually wake up and
they say
guys
like they're like the world the doc is
the deck is stuck against you isn't it
and and well and relationship wise yeah
i mean what we can get into why is the
stack together these these guys go for
women like that if you're dating a woman
like that you're getting what you
deserve when a guy gets in on a
relationship yeah when who's taking half
the [ __ ] when they leave the guy's not
taking half the [ __ ] the woman's taking
half the [ __ ] you're dating that girl as
opposed to dating someone who's making
whatever idiot wipes that up into the
sign of prenup that's awesome but that's
awesome but the point is fresh and fit
wake up and they try to
basically encourage male excellence they
say men do better they said there's a
famous quote between in the manosphere
the red pill community rolo the
manosphere yeah there's a whole thing
out there i mean we get these guys on
here they know
they say make money
make muscles
have game and hold frame what does that
mean
like rather than pursuing women pursue
excellence
change women should be doing by the way
on both sides i don't know about all
that that's what women should be doing
i don't know if women should be having
the same goals as men well pursue
excellence is pretty general everyone
should pursue success that's not just
them feeling good about them men and
women excellence is is different but do
you see what he's talking about we can
get to that in a second he didn't say
anything she said he goes who said on
the show
if i wanted that's like you saying to me
you're picking one girl out of literally
i have seen a lot of thousands that
they've seen how many women do they have
like me on the show i'm curious
they've had women like michaela peterson
on they've had like intelligent women
okay that's a good example they've had
uh brody she's been on the show she's
been on my show they've had um but the
question is how does that work out for
those women
how do you mean i mean both from fresh
and fit and from their audience
like how do those women get treated by
fresh and fit i've been there they don't
disrespect like here's the i don't see
it as disrespectful no because
when you put a mic in front of somebody
whether it's this girl or how many other
girls were looking on in disgust about
what she was saying by the way i don't
know if you want to play that clip back
without audio yeah it is as as we're
looking at it the other girls were
looking at her like you dumb [ __ ]
they were were they not well yeah
because they're they're they're
basically disrespecting women they're
making it hard for women like me but
because the women were looking at the
women were looking at her in discussion
but do you understand all they said was
what are you bringing to the table and
she said me do you understand that he
they want to talk about male excellence
in order to to make their talking point
they're choosing to book someone who's
trying to take advantage of men who's
trying to manipulate them to expose what
men need to look out for that's not the
norm of women well that's a norm in
miami that's i don't know how you hang
out adam but that is not the norm most
women are not that's the norm in l.a
that's enormous no it's not
no it's not and it's not the norm in new
york either what percentage what are you
hanging out with that's the norm among
them new york is a little bit different
because new york you got to [ __ ] if
you can make it there you can make it
anywhere thank you so new york like new
york i just came back from new york i
don't even touch on that but new york
women have to work because you can't
just parade in a bikini all day why
because it's cold as [ __ ]
okay you can't just be like you can't do
the naked cowboy thing in new york in
miami you could do that you could worse
give me clothes
people do skimp in new york in the
winter there's girls in mini skirts in
lounges dancing why are they doing that
but but do you want to because they want
to stay warm or because they want to
look sexually attractive to men but
there's something called the sexual
marketplace and we're all competing in
it okay i'm not
well you were i wasn't so you got wifed
up i actually walked in there but i
wasn't i was just being me that's what
you're hanging out with
of course you're you're hanging out with
the wrong you're every girl is competing
i wasn't do you wear high heels
rarely do you wear makeup sometimes you
do your hair now you do your hair do you
see what do you work out
yeah the point is you want to look good
i have never ever wanted to look good
for a man darling who do you want to
look good for for myself because stop it
okay let me ask you a question when you
go to bed you keep your makeup on or off
the only reason i have makeup on right
now is because i'm sitting okay because
you want to look good for me
for me i don't need to look good for me
when i'm in the bed
do you want to look good in on the
camera
listen first of all you know i'm married
right so i'm not trying to impress
anybody okay but in order to get your
husband you want to leave i didn't play
that game i didn't play that game what
do you mean you it's hard for you to
believe
that that what we saw that woman right
there is not in the majority but it's
not and i don't think she's there
women most women out there look at that
and they're like that's disgusting
that's disgusting what percentage of
women do you think have her philosophy
very small what percentage i don't know
across the country yeah united states
less than five oh
jed
i don't know any women like that i don't
know any women you realize that's
glorified prostitution she's saying what
is she saying she's saying i'm going to
dress up i'm going to look nice you're
going to pay for my [ __ ] let's say it's
more than five percent it's ten percent
i would say it's about
and depending on the city twenty percent
i would it's like in new york so you're
familiar with the 80 20 world the pareto
principle right yeah so in new york
where rent's more expensive you got to
work your ass off things are tougher you
got to be a like a worker i mean you
really have to yeah buckle down like a
hustle i would say it's closer to 80
percent workers 20 women who rely on
their looks
there's other cities like in miami
i don't know if it's as much as 80 20
but i know it's more than 50 50. where a
large percentage a large swath of women
rely on their looks whether that's
looking good to have a man whether
that's
only fans whether that's tripping
whether it's modeling whether that's
bikinis whether that's just like
dressing up to go find a boyfriend that
is very prevalent here in south florida
for sure and just like it is in a lot of
major cities la for sure
so that
that's
they're in miami now if they were doing
that show in
boise idaho i'd be like what the what
the hell is going on in the water idaho
but this is the reality for a lot of
women out there and they're basically
just saying men
understand how these women think and
just be prepared how those women think i
wouldn't say all those women think
correct and that's who's showcased
repeatedly every time i open a podcast
we have more examples here and i see
hosts like fresh and fit style i see
these talking points from guys that
sound like that like what we described
and i see these bimbo-ish women all the
time they are purposely picking these
bimbo-ish you know i want to take
advantage of a man and it's fine because
i'm cute like these aren't let me ask
you a question then
um if there weren't that this many women
why do they always have 10 bimbos on
every night it seems like there's a lot
of them running around there and i don't
listen i don't know and they're not like
recurring characters like they're really
passing i don't know these they're out
there some of these women there's more
women like that than there are women
like you especially in miami no i'm
telling you well i don't know i think
adam's right in miami in miami in l.a
maybe not new york in these big cities
they've all been new york isn't like
that at all i can tell you straight up
new york women will kick some ass but
they've all been hit by the
influencer kim kardashian they all want
to be trophy we live in a world now okay
you're first of all like i don't know
listen you may have your finger on the
pulse of miami i'll give you that or los
angeles um although i think los angeles
or i would also say
like
i go out to
bars
lounges night clubs not as much
i'm out i used to work in bars so i get
it i used to work in bars i used to work
in lounges i was cocktail waitress for
years i get it
but
we're living in the united states we've
got a whole country here and what i'm
saying is people are watching podcasts
all over the country you got women
watching this being like who are these
women
who are these women put some women on i
do know a lot of good girls in the
midwest there you go but they're not
all that's more 80 20 but you had a hard
time what bothers me is you had a hard
time believing because you're used to
now we're used to seeing these women by
the way i would never play with a girl
like that like if i would tell if i'm
fresh and fit i 100 agree with them
expose this girl for who she is and
advise men stay away from them from
women like that but there's going to be
a guy out there who's like she's hot and
i've got money i'll deal with it and
that's on that idiot exactly if you like
the short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here